If one wishes to discover their highest value
and status in life, it is helpful to consider
the basic economic model of supply and demand.
A good or service is valued higher when there
is a limited supply of said good or service,
coupled with a high desire for it.
Likewise, a person who is unique and in low
supply, but high in demand and interest to
humankind will acquire significant higher
value and status in life.
In order to discover your value in this life,
you must not be afraid of finding and embracing
your unique self and sharing it with the world.
Not everyone is a person of low supply and
high demand.
If everyone was, than there would no longer
be a low supply, and consequently, no longer
would anyone be uniquely valuable.
Just like how government bodies and economies
self-regulate supply and demand, so does nature
with greatness and human value.
Everyone possesses some form and degree of
greatness, but only some of us possess truly
unique and sovereign greatness.
Greatness that slices through all the noise
of the world and yields collective impact,
high virtue, wealth, fame, and power.
In order to better understand the distribution
and separation of human greatness, it is helpful
to consider a species outside of humanity;
the bumblebee.
Consider the queen bee.
A queen bee is born a queen bee.
It is born into higher value and status as
a result of its ability to fulfill a role
that is in low supply and high demand within
its beehive.
Whether the bee wants it or not, it is queen.
Likewise, whether you want to or or not, you
may possess unique greatness.
The difference between bees and us is that
bees are immensely less complex.
Human culture is far more complicated and
on a much larger scale than that of a beehive.
Our higher level of consciousness and cultural
complexity imposes a significant difference
on the process of determining who is what
kind of bee in the human world.
Unlike a beehive, there is room in the human
world for far more queen bees than the one-per-hive
dynamic of the bee world.
Through mass media and mass communication,
our human hives have become enormously large.
Our boundaries extend beyond our immediately
surrounding communities and as a result, human
greatness is far more widespread, complex,
and malleable.
If this is true, how does one know how uniquely
and ultimately great they are?
How does one know what kind of bee they are
and where they fit in the human hive that
is the world?
There are seemingly arbitrary conditions that
foster unique greatness within humans.
And the process of rising to one’s highest
self and developing ultimate greatness is
one of extreme confusion, resistance, and
often inequality.
Amidst the density of culture and social constructs,
it often becomes easy for humans of unique
greatness to be reduced down to lower worths
and statuses.
And this gives opportunity for humans who
lack real unique greatness, but merely have
more fortunate life circumstances, to be built
up into higher worth’s and statuses.
It is therefore, the obligation of every individual,
both for the benefit of themselves and the
collective quality of humankind, to oppose
the resistance of life and fight tooth and
nail for their greatness in hopes that it
may be low in supply and high in demand.
One must go to the end of the world for their
beliefs, ideas, and ambitions.
One must trust that they are worth as mush
as they think they are and work untiringly
throughout life to prove it.
With attention, conviction, and action, your
greatness will manifest into its particular
value and you will find out how great it truly
is.